from there we'll season them by salt
pepper okay good boy let's go ah so got
boiling water in it okay so pepper some
pepper yes there's your salt right comes
you have it but now we're gonna glaze
the chips with olive oil that's
absolutely paramount and weed lays with
olive oil starting from stick in the
oven so drizzle the olive all over the
chips yeah give that I'm drizzling up
come drizzling good boy good boy
thank you good good give that little
shake yeah we're gonna season it okay
with some chili flakes come on Chris
stay with me not two miles apart with
the one yet the two legs yeah okay
all right don't know now not too much
you put cheese also you go out yeah I
like I like not too many cuz you'll
never get too hot yes that right is that
enough your bear little toss just wait
okay right now okay give a good shake
yep now once you're shaking yes okay
bend down get your tray out come on guys
stay with me yes let me stay with me
tray out tray out and potatoes on the
tray and look huh that's the noise you
want that's the noise okay now that's
the noise
right now